hello there reject nation Greg Alva here
John Humphrey mandalorian official
trailer numero dos has drop or Disney
Plus we aren't going to be covering this
series here on the channel so I'd say
subscribe right now and click that
notification valve we already got an
editor for this and recover ironic
what's up buddy let's swing on into
action now shall we i say covering it i
mean a reaction
my peaceful man since the revolution it
is a shame that your people suffered but
bounty hunting is a complicated process
[Music]
[Music]
let's say to you becoming
they said you were the best in the
persik that's in the parsec huh
Oh
it's at parsing star wars-themed
dang dude
[Music]
and space battles
Carl Weathers
[Music]
yeah good
and speaks I just want to watch
Mandalorian trailers over and over and
over again answer your question John I
think that was Bill burr actually no
bird every now and again gets a weird
casting announcement where everyone
freaks out I mean I didn't see him here
Google there is that your whole EQ made
it into the trailer so surprising I'm
loving this so much you know if you
watched our first reaction we're
skeptical pretty skeptical I don't think
we're ever hating ourselves from what we
saw before you know like I'm sure
there's a lot of Easter eggs and nuggets
that people are probably gonna be able
to pick up on much better than people
like ourselves from its connection to
like Clone Wars or rebels and stuff
people who watch those animated shows
are probably able to pick up on a little
bit more my new details that are you
know sprinkled in here better than us I
think that's why I gotta just start
watching all those animated shows yeah
because I feel like I'm missing out on
something we watched a few weeks back
from the Clone Wars it's pretty rad with
the action especially in stuff what this
trailer gave me though more than the
last one the other one had more of this
atmospheric mood sort of a western tone
to it and this had a lot more of the
space adventure time yeah which I think
is necessary to starburst or I don't
want to get too big with space battles
and space Wars and all that you know
it's like yes it is a Star Wars story
essential ingredient it's not like it's
like whoa what the hell is this dude in
this show yeah from the first trailer
like the very grounded
ominous approach that they had this
definitely felt a little bit more pg-13
everyone's like could it be arc is nice
in half by the door which they didn't
yeah this one has a little bit more of a
traditional Star Wars feel to it so if
you kind of have a resemblance of from
the last trailer and this one I think
it's a perfect one-two combo and on
there I don't need any more trailers
honestly oh yeah oh so this is how great
this show looks and this harken back in
ways that I thought were were nice
because especially in the now time we're
always referencing a no moshing but
especially with the you know episodic
Star Wars movies of late there has been
a lot of
made about whether or not it's too much
opening of this was really nice just
with those like slow shots watching the
scenery and stuff it reminded me of the
old Star Wars in a way that didn't seem
like it was engineered to write and I
like that this really seems like it's
taking place in like a corner of the
universe because even with the space
battles they don't look big and scopic
the way the movies do they look like
it's one ship on one so maybe I'm
thinking with the western vibe part of a
Western anyway is you know travelling
long distances so like you know maybe
the ship is kind of like your horse and
then maybe they'll get like jumped mid
space but I can't imagine yeah that they
would have the budget to make that just
all the time bad weapon that he's
holding at the end looks so familiar I
know right I bet the one he wears in the
kriti of rocks in the Christmas special
that's just well maybe
or is there a toy package with it or is
it just that like there's another gun in
another sci-fi that looks just like it
and you know I'm pretty sure that is cuz
jon favreau is reportedly a fan of that
special oh yeah I must I mean yes it has
to be it has to be like every little
detail I assume is tweaked heavily no
Starbucks cups here okay well guys look
I can't wait for this good look a better
glimpse at all the whole cat you say you
got see Gina Carano in here Giancarlo
Esposito another is like the same look
we saw him before her actually shot a
couple of the same establish new
establishing shot can't get over the
fact that were hers and this did make it
seem like he is talking directly to the
mandalorian so like you know it seems
like he is the big yeah you know and I'm
like the more this approaches the more
like wow Hertzog is gonna dead it
doesn't say the action looks just but I
also here in Pedro Pascal that's amore
soon as Petrov speaking at that dinner
at that moment I thought the audio of it
was really good because there some
reason I imagine it would sound a lot
more muffled yeah yeah or in the radio
town but I'm like that's just the right
amount of stereo in there and that's one
that's a detail of Star Wars that people
don't often point out but that somehow I
always enjoy is the weird you know vocal
manipulations with everyone's masks yes
it's it's fun alright guys well I've
already got your Disney Plus
subscription got any theories about the
show
comment below y'all can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
beli get notified when I got a YouTube
video up keep a lookout for when we are
doing reactions ten minute highlights
for this show over here on this channel
I like to end this with a page from the
day shout out to a woman named L B lb
you are our last patron of the day shout
out for the month of October and when we
talked recently you were telling me that
some stuff was not going so well you got
sick he got into a car accident
oh well for every time you someone is
experiencing something terrible that
could mean with the right mentality
there's something good right around the
corner and do you know what that is I'm
sending you mail blow-up dolls oh yeah
that don't get too specific
I won't disney plus trailer definitely
no no no ro that's just a great way to
relieve tension you know and take your
mind off of all the misfortunes in fact
you could discover a whole new area of
your life and you know get lost in it
you are the first patron to be receiving
this from us hopefully not the laughing
out the last let's see how this goes
let us know in great detail family fruit